and the Eureka moment for me was the  notion that the blockchain could create  a permissionless transaction between two  parties that may not know each other  don't necessarily have to trust each  other but over the blockchain they can  make this transaction by creating a  decentralized effect taking out third  parties and this is something that I  think is the Eureka moment and if you go  back and study gold and you understand  why this precious metal has value about  five or six percent of the cost of gold  would be for the manufacturing effect  that gold has on our society the rest of  it is the perception of that store of  value and I think I think this crypto  currency Revolution and Bitcoin  specifically because of its scarcity and  it's being adopted quite rapidly as a  result of which the prices are going to  go a lot higher